okay well let's see four people joining
this livestream this is a meeting whose
title I didn't quite understand so I
hope I'm about to be it's called bite
pairing coding encoder and decoder so I
hope I'm about to be enlightened about
what this is actually about and by the
way let's see um just wish my hair could
you um put tokenizer x' in our spelling
list and tokenization x' in a spelling
list we'll skip that ridiculous German
word um
okay go ahead what is this okay cool so
this is actually a very very nice new
feature 412 and it basically is about
tokenization so currently we've got two
different ways of tokenizing sentences
so there's characters and there's tokens
the negative of characters is that you
basically have no you know like English
you have a lot of information from like
what words are exist ready in English so
character level models in general for
neural networks they train much slower
you need a lot more data to train them
because they have to learn things like
spelling on the other hand tokens which
is like finding words so let's tokenizer
for example it'll find you no spaces or
sentences and it will try and create
some list of tokens it has to all kinds
of special logic for dealing with
punctuation whatnot so the promise this
is that's for English you can maybe make
this work with took with normal tokens
but as soon as you enter things like
machine translation all kinds of crazy
things happen in other languages so for
example German together and yeah so so
basically there's a solution now that
has become the the standards methods for
things like machine translation and all
kinds of other NOP tasks and it's
basically a trained tokenizer so it's
all a second in our tokens the thing you
showed with that net encoder with tokens
I don't know what that mapping is and I
mean we have burnt in some mapping some
default mapping to the net encoder with
tokens
correct correct so it's basically it's
the English dictionary it's wordlist or
something for English
I think it's equivalent to this there
are a couple things in a word list that
we remove like what honestly what reason
and and and why I mean so so an example
of something is happening to wordless
the default if you're using that one
there are many different kinds of
wordless so for example the default in
version twelve excludes
words that basically aren't suitable for
aren't g-rated words okay so we had
removed previously by default so
wordlist has an option i forget what
we're now calling it um
it used to be called gosh I don't
remember we went through so many
different iterations of this of this
thing but I think it you know for
example there are words which are
definitively bad there are words that
can be interpreted badly there are words
that will involve tittering among the
the middle school kids that kind of
thing and we have a variety of choices
of those and I think there's some
default setting that won't include all
kinds of profanities and things so I
don't know what you're exactly using
here but whatever that mapping whatever
that thing is don't assume that the
numbers you get out will be in any way
stable no we don't just we don't assume
that okay so once you I mean the thing
is once you once you've created that net
encoder it stores the full word list in
it so it is our is that yeah exactly
um yeah we the the things that are right
now and someone on the live stream is
commenting it's common words and known
words yeah that's what they're called
right now we have it we have a new
option which has many settings that
determine whether all kinds of words
that that some of which are probably
unsuitable for live streaming or
anything none okay okay so anyway so
this is a new approach that does not is
not based on words I don't know why we
call it tokens rather than calling it
words
I mean characters and words seems to me
to make more sense given that that thing
is coming from a word list and the other
one is coming from an
for that nicer tokens can be more
general than words so they could be okay
but what are we doing and can I see the
rotation formatting code of tokens sure
okay so for something like New York
might be a token but that's stuck to
words sure okay
oh yes very language so this will be all
right fine and there's what kinds of
case you know things about like ignoring
case and slip patterns
yup okay I got it okay okay so it's a
messy business and a yeah it doesn't
scale for each other I know some mustard
does not but go ahead okay okay so
basically yeah this is new approach all
right fine I believe you so call me yes
okay cool so basically beeping could it
just has paper says they called sub word
units so it can learn pieces of words
okay I got it
and so second interpolation between
connected nice yes trains there some
libraries that you're training I mean is
I hope it's not primarily you know these
glutinous of languages and so on of
which I think Hungarian and Finnish have
even more bizarre kinds of setups I mean
that's a yeah okay I I hope it's not
sort of just optimized for those but go
ahead absolutely not
so the main way that people use this is
probably gonna be violet model so we
have for example there's one site that
has okay fine what is your proposal okay
cool so this context is important for
the design so basically there's two
different philosophies we can take fall
for this design so the first one is that
we allow people to specify listen could
like normal encoders like you give all
information that's required to construct
it so like you give a token list it has
a whole bunch of parameters on the other
hand no one will actually ever use no
they'll never do it it's way too
complicated okay so basically we think
for
twelve there's a very simple solution so
I was in that model will give people you
know those 10 and 75 pre-trained models
but will also support a foul syntax one
so basically net and could be P encoder
file that will take a googol sentence P
spree train model and it'll create
constructor net encoder why are we doing
that why don't we just put those
internet model you means that these are
arbitrary ones that somebody else has
produced yes that's a toolkit that you
can use to train your and train you and
so that we can't do training of this PP
in code oh we won't be able to do
training directly right not immediately
but I don't see any reason why we can't
have what kind of disgust involved I
mean this is a feature detector of some
kind that needs to be trained yes yeah
yeah basically like you know training
string one Bob blood will get some
corpus of either strings or they might
be a text file or something that you
trained on I don't particularly yeah I
don't want to commit us to that syntax
because I think there might need to be
other options I check valve min to be a
lot more detail about what the training
corpus is just having a great big blob
of you know here's a gigabyte of text be
happy doesn't yeah so one possibility is
net encode a train or encode a train or
train and code something like that
because then it's not the only encoder
that you might beat you might want to
train but that's a whole nother can
can't we don't design hold on hold on
thing I mean the fact is for the typical
languages you know whatever it is these
275 languages or whatever it is what's
wrong with those encoders I mean so
there'll be some standard encoders that
come from the net model what's wrong
with those why would somebody want to do
something different other than for
research purposes so they might have you
know something else like they might have
their training on sequel language or
something okay well they might they
might don't we also have chemicals
okay fine but I don't understand I mean
they can write their own encoder period
from from from scratch what's special
what's the okay what is the
characteristic of a bpe encoder
what does BP even stand for it's some
sort by pan coding okay so what does
that mean so basically that means the
destination is there something goes in
and byte pairs come out is that correct
no hmm it works in there's like in the
same ways other as other tokenizer x' so
you give it a string and it returns you
a list of number of integers right why's
it called byte power it's a detail of
Hart's implemented it's not even a very
good description of Hearts and in a byte
power would get you 65,000 possibilities
is that what it does no that's that's
why it's a bad man what is it what is it
tell me what it is hey what is it be
what does Piper why is it called byte it
comes from the oh sorry Mattel continued
a couple we can't hear you
we can't hear you it's basically it
inherits the name from a compression
algorithm which which nothing to do with
like language and tokenization of
strings but just with byte sequences and
it's a compression algorithm which
basically you you count all the
possibilities and pair of bytes and and
you create a new symbol for the very
frequent pair of bytes
it's just that okay but okay so it found
it finds good pieces just naturally when
you do that the compression and grab so
it's finding common engrams yes common
diagrams so
okay I mean and you think it should be
called be PE encoder even though it's a
bad name well we're not so it could be I
mean yeah like by pair that doesn't suit
anything because it's the least of all
at least bad of all the different
objects fine okay um all right okay
okay so now explain to me okay so most
of the time people are going to use the
encoders they don't care whether they're
a be PE encoder or anything else
there'll be an encoder for a given
language right if this is the best
encoder to use for English why not just
have them why not just have a net
encoder you know language or something
maybe but I mean even they're like the
kinds of characters you see in Twitter
so very different from what you'd get
from like a more traditional yeah I
understand but but okay so how does
somebody make a BP encoder right now so
yeah let me just lay out what I think we
should do the phase one is just get
things from net from them want model
gallery right and that's the only thing
people can do phase two is they can use
their own by hook or by crook they get
their hands on a sentence piece encoder
and it's just a file that just describes
their own what what format is that file
in it's a pretty powerful it's great but
what format is the pure buff in so to
speak what's inside there so it's it's a
bunch of metadata so things like the
chunks the Chokin tank token yes but
just saying it's protobuf doesn't tell
one another thing right I mean it's like
saying it's JSON and it you know but
then what how do we decoy file credit I
mean look pretty buff is different from
JSON in that it actually has a schema so
there's this Hema full sentence piece
encoders and my point is with this file
syntax it's like it's like we supported
an import but it's just something we can
actually deliver for this version that's
quite lightweight there's nothing more
to say then it's sentence piece
is a weird file format you imported you
get a BPA token encoder we don't need to
make an import page for this one weird
one sort format we can just support it
in the construction spec asking somebody
is noticing that you have an eclipse
icon in your that that's not my screen
that's Sebastian's screen that we're
watching now just in case you're
wondering um I'm we have a nice welcome
workbench but well well spotted good
screen tour so you see what we're saying
we're saying you can make your own you
can train your own thing using
off-the-shelf software it's not part of
Mathematica and what once you've done
that and you want to load that encode it
in you can do that using this file spec
okay but what why don't we give it a
name I mean is there a format name it's
pointless
it's pointless to do that because it
creates a lot of work for us and the
only thing you'll ever do with this
it'll become a net encoder you can't
explore no I get it but I get a bit but
this is not just some random file from
the wild web so to speak this is a file
in some very specific format created by
some very specific you know system
that's training bpe encoders yes yes
okay so what is that thing that is
creating that file sense piece which was
thing called sentence piece yeah okay
it's a library called sentence piece so
it will be described as a sentence piece
file was that correct yes yes yeah okay
so it's as if we had a thing which was
in our import an import format called
sentence piece and that or sentence
piece encoder or something format we
could call it sentence piece encoder and
that what that does is you read that in
and it becomes a net encoder in other
words that's an import format and what
it returns is net encoder of blah blah
blah yes
we don't propose to do it that way for a
couple reasons but yes theoretically yes
why don't you want to do it that way
because there's no because for now
there's no other way you you could
create one of these net encoders in the
first place so if you're thinking about
what the actual usage line of this net
encoder is the only way you
create one is from one of these files
all right fine well fine so you say a
sentence piece file in protobuf format
or whatever and you just just define it
that way I mean it's kind of a um like a
deus ex what
it's a deus ex it just comes out of just
god made these and you know o deus ex
machina hi right okay sorry my my Latin
pronunciation is not
eaten level no they've changed all the
lesson pronounciation since I learnt it
how that could happen after two thousand
years let's not worry about that um okay
yes document this thing as an as a as a
problem with that but what's more
important is that for for English for
example the default what's going to be
the name how is this going to pick up
the default English encoder okay so I
think there's a Fetty so a few things we
can do here so I think the the zero
argue inform should do something similar
to what tokens County does and tokens
does have this form web yeah we're up
common language like English or
something fine yeah that could be
Network basically that's fine I'm good
with that I mean we have to have a
standard Lea named what will be the name
of the net model that this accesses
here's what we want is that a
standardized name so that if for example
that second thing is SQL or something
like this then we could imagine having a
standard Lea trained I mean if you think
that this is you know the wonderful
encoding for natural language then I
think having bpe tokens in there is
rather obscure I mean why not call it
something which is a bit more actually
but suggested calling on our live
students to just sub word tokens as a
more generic name it's not bad
I'm not sure that the word capitalized I
think it would be sub word with a
lowercase W I I personally think that
that's a lot better than be PE tokens
which is kind of meaningless the the
spot that that puts us in design-wise is
that if they're more if there's more
than one method so we're token is a sort
of general concept right and if there's
more than one method then all the sort
of parameters that this encoder has
inside it and the implementation it has
we have to sort of multiplex multiple of
those into one net encode aspect we
could call it be P sub word tokens that
people that way people have a fighting
chance of knowing what the thing is yeah
I do prefer the pieces I would be peter
pan's okay good thank you your credit
for this
okay this is live record that will be
there for internecine twitch let's queue
for better or worse okay um okay so keep
going down parameters that we need so
these are all Mattel maybe will show
these parameters who's gonna share the
screen actually quite interesting from
Wolfram language in general okay Matteo
we're waiting share your screen okay so
this Unicode normalization so how could
you go to 125 percent magnification sure
better yep it's fine so so Unicode
normalization is a pre-processing step
in which you basically resolve some
redundancy in the Unicode representation
in this case in utf-8 representation so
for example like these two characters so
okay
on this front and they don't have set
exactly the same but in general they can
and they are semantically the same I
understand so we've do you know I mean
within our character data setup we've
got all kinds of transformations and
maybe not this one but this one might be
an interesting one to have ok the
interesting one to have so let's see who
could somebody maybe get some the I
don't think we have the right people to
talk about this in general because we've
got have I mean this also relates to
transliterate and those kinds of things
no this is interesting yeah ok
ok so there are various schemes of utf-8
normalization and they're basically
defined by by by through placement
tables yeah right ok so another thing
can somebody ask somebody contact Allen
and just ask him to either join this for
a minute or two tell us who is deals
with character data and get them to join
us ok I think my Francisco might be the
person doing that I can't remember
ok ok ok
so there are various schemes and like we
currently support these particular ones
this is an FK c plus a custom modified
version which which people for sentence
based implemented which I mean we have a
question for this because it's unclear
how to name it yeah I understand ok so
first point is there's this sort of
folding of Unicode space to things which
are to the minimal code point that
visually looks like something is that
the basic idea that that's some ugly of
of these schemes have these purpose ok
fine so
so that or it could be um allow turns
into u double dot or whatever that the
idea yes yes okay it's about to resolve
redundancies no I understand I
understand but that's not unrelated to
transliteration which is well supported
by this library what is it called CTE
gosh I forget what it's called there's a
library that goes along with Unicode
that supports romanization and that we
have been progressively adding to okay
so ignore case that seems perfectly
reasonable what is there an issue so
well there is no particular issue for
this like the only additional piece of
information is that basically this
library supports generic utf-8 case
folding which which covers like all the
weird you can face correct oh yeah yeah
I know what would so distill this to
upper case from upper case I mean this
has been okay
extensively worked on over the years
okay so then we have visual whitespace
basically can insert it's another
pre-processing step which inserts a
white space either to the left or the
right of this job the input string and
this is done in order to segment the the
input string correctly according to how
BP works so I can go a little bit
unbelievably detailed thing about this
particular scheme these these extra
options here pretty obscure yeah they
needed because certain model okay so
what is your objective in this meeting
you want names for these options okay so
decider named self the only part we are
testing options right yes
western options yeah the only thing
we're unsure what to do is how to call
this modify enough KC scheme and again
we need it
because it's the defaulting sentence
piece a lot of call it modified and I've
Casey if that's what you're calling it
just call it modified NF Casey I mean
all of these things at this point are
kind of you know telling jokes by
numbers but you have to understand what
all this stuff means or you just have to
copy it from some example or you're not
going anywhere about it this is hardly a
first principle situation sure sure
well but do we do we also we probably it
we've already care abouts also
explaining how this modified SK and fkc
is modified from the original and I
don't think so people will just try it
and see if it works okay I just I would
just call it modified NF KC and say
that's the default okay I mean this
stuff is still in fairly rapid motion
it's not going to you know I would hope
that within a year at the most we will
be able to have sort of the definitive
language encoder and that's just the
thing people should use we don't have
that yet because and in fact that's what
you were proposing at the top that
modified it for either an F Casey so I I
just loop back to what you already had
figured out okay um okay so this
additional whitespace thing yes I did
white space for something I did once
page when such at white space what about
padding we do have a good idea white
space hmm that's good point
the left and right okay sounds good and
yeah so I'm in the meeting we had we
didn't call it pre merge we just call it
merge white space okay yeah well what
does it - yeah that's another fairly
technical option so basically like in
this algorithm the way you you start is
that you first you segment a nibble
string into the characters and then you
start merging ideas and symbols
according to some
it's ok when you enable this
pre-marriage white space the first thing
you do without even looking at your
model definition is to merge the white
space either on the right or on the left
top of the world and then go on with
what your model defines okay I get it um
actually merged white space is not a
good name no what what what what
collapse white space that was one of the
options that we discussed earlier today
that's another this year another one
actually okay but we've got to actually
look at all of them
well is there another one this term
completes apparently all these things
are symbol names screen names right yes
yeah these are all strings so basically
this guy sorry
folds it basically collapses a decent
white space to one so we didn't call it
combined effect didn't we call it
collapse no that I think combined is
right for what you're talking about here
oh my god I understand yeah I understand
okay so this merge thing gosh I don't
know um you know it's unbelievably
technical I mean just call it the three
merge whitespace what's that yeah I
think it doesn't matter too much for
this again like uses on setting these
options okay so call it pre merge
whitespace and we'll be good okay what
else is there to figure out here I think
that's that's pretty much it okay okay
um so this unicode normalization thing
um seems like um that would be an
interesting option for things related to
transliterate um and we should you
should communicate that to Alan and
Francisco so Sushma maybe you can do
that
ah and I mean what we probably should do
here if you give me back the screen sure
um
and that way we'll find out only the
applications that I have as opposed to
people are asking here on the on the
livestream about um whether people
prefer using wolfing desktop Mathematica
or from workbench for um yeah the answer
is that a lot of people who write really
large blobs of code and interact a lot
with them how it gets system and so on
do often use whorfin workbench and
there's a pretty nice integration which
hopefully will make available one of
these days to the public integration
with git that's been built there um and
but but people like me um who write
smaller lumps of Wolff language code
tend to use notebooks and package files
and I think fairly common is to use some
is not doing that
hold on one second um I just want to
look at these character encoding things
for a second um and hopefully I will be
able to use let's see there's the
version twelve head branch build
yeah fairly common is to use package
files and the package editor but failing
that and that's sort of the junior
version of workbench II type stuff okay
let me just take a look at the all the
stuff to do with character names um yeah
the the first people are pointing out
that string option string names and
these net encoders are annoying to not
be symbols but they don't really raise
to the level of being symbols that have
global usage they're really things that
are part of a very local function not
the best thing but um you know this is
still an area in rapid development um
okay let me just look at this um stuff
to do with character functionality um
you just go to one of these let's hope
this is working now today okay
okay what I'm looking for is hmm I
wonder why this
from hmm that
not good this really should have
transliteration and things on it huh
transliterate that's okay so that's a
transliteration operation that will take
this and turn them into that right but
what you're saying is that effectively
this thing is like a transliteration but
it will take it will reduce things to
canonicalized Unicode code points is
that correct by the way could you um I
don't know why that's read but can you
report that um so it's possible that
trans that we could put this thing into
transliterated I think I'm trying to
think about ok remove diacritics is
another related thing make sense um
yeah I mean perhaps that should even be
a function for canonicalizing characters
because I agree that this is useful or
is it just is it basically
transliteration - I don't think it is I
think it's very specific to Unicode
because it's you know it's different
it's kind of likely Unicode spec defines
what what makes two you know two
character to Unicode code points the
same thing no it doesn't they're not the
same thing they're never the same thing
I mean a very exact typical example of
that would be you know capital alpha
right there it is yeah hey all right
and it looks like that and now let me
put in a capital A okay looks like that
in that font so the question is I assume
that your normalization would take that
capital alpha and just turn it into a
capital A it's a couple out for one of
our things or was that in Unicode what's
of course the Unicode code point I mean
if I say two character code of this
it'll be about nine hundred and
something I think there's a reserved
space that we put all kinds of things
including that's different that what
that that's private Unicode space that's
quite different that's up in this that's
up close to 65 K 64 K right this is this
is all standard unicode our mapping of
things like the name capital alpha is
special to us but the fact that it is a
Unicode code point at 9:13 is just you
know that's just it is what it is right
okay
okay so what I'm saying is this is what
you're talking about I assume in that
normalization is you could take code
point nine thirteen and see what it maps
to maybe you can tell us Matteo what it
maps to that no I just run it just run
it oh sure just take your net encoder
and type in a capital alpha and tell us
what it gives you and I predict it's
going to give you 65
well it's not that simple because that
that's that's a pre-processing step and
then it has to run through the matching
of the tokens yeah okay so that might
not work but the main way to run it and
on just run it on the two separate
strings and see if it's the same but
that's an easy way to do it um but it's
not this shouldn't do this so so it
shouldn't converse alpha into a why
that's exactly what it was trying to do
here if it's gonna convert you know so
that's the whole point it's folding
things so that my understanding of this
is well is that there's different ways
of representing the same grapheme from
unicode's point of view like for example
you can start with an A and add a
diacritic on it using a combining
unicode character that combines the
previous one besides they consider that
it's a degenerate representation of the
same grapheme and unicode has an opinion
about what those rules are and this is
what it's meant to do is canonicalize
them to one version of each of those
privileged classes
it's not about transliteration that's
the wrong way to think about it okay
listen we've got people who are experts
on this whole Unicode standard and
they're not people who are in this
meeting I mean as an amateur so to speak
there are these things you are
completely correct there are languages
where you know they come from dead keys
on keyboards and they're characters that
are like that that work like that I
think in more exotic cases there are I
think camere has one of the most exotic
things which has languages with with you
know hats and feet and other all sorts
of diacritics all over the place um and
you know I'm not the expert on this I
understand this seems like um look
basically what we're doing right now is
we're simply trying to get an encoder
which does a sensible thing for typical
pieces of language and I think it's an
interesting point that there should be
something that canonical eise's those
things that
will be a good point for Alan and
Francisco when they're working on
character data but I think it's not
relevant to this um okay anything else
we need to go over guys
I hope this is we're getting to the 11th
power obviously hopefully you guys are
getting everything together for the
final builds yes yes there was there was
one thing that I wanted to run by you
but yeah a read-a-thon but where did it
go
ah the question is does the unicode
function work with emoji the answer is
for version 12 although we're not making
big noise about it emoji will work in
the kernel emoji are not plain zero
unicode there are there unicode
characters above 65,000 and in we are
now supporting in the kernel multi by a
more than two byte unicode characters
but we don't yet have display on all
platforms of those things so for example
the emoji you just put in I would
strongly suspect I don't know how to get
it out of this so oh well so much for
that it seems to be a bitmap um the the
answer is that at the kernel level we
will be supporting emoji starting in 12
oh and soon thereafter they will start
to be able to be displayed properly in
the front end and so on on all platforms
it's that's been a very complicated
thing to support efficiently sorry tell
you what we're going to ask tally yeah I
can't I can't find my note I'll just
have to ask you another time okay sounds
good
okay well four people on the live stream
we are about to start a general language
design livestream and preview what's our
agenda okay all kinds of all kinds of
things coming all right
um so we'll be back on villa livestream
and you know on that work folk talk to
y'all soon
Thanks okay